bonjour à tous la semaine dernière les
sénateurs de la mission d'information
sur l'accès aux documents administratifs
et aux données publiques a auditionné
les représentants du conseil national du
numérique et notamment le président de
ce conseil benoît thieulin alors ce
conseil qu'est ce que c'est c'est une
instance qui comporte une trentaine de
personnes aussi bien des universitaires
que des présidents de start up et qui
joue le rôle d'interface entre les
décideurs publics et les acteurs du
monde du numérique pour ce conseil le
mouvement d'ouverture des données
aujourd'hui en marche est un sujet
essentiel et s'il estime qu'il faut
tendre vers une gouvernance ouverte
notamment faire en sorte que la société
civile comprennent les mécanismes qui
préside une décision publique il met
aussi l'accent sur la question de la
protection des données
une question qui a été largement mise en
avant récemment par la farce nadene tout
de suite donc retour à cette audition
qui s'est tenue la semaine dernière en
salle médicis bien mesdames messieurs
donc sur proposition du groupe écologie
su sénat a été décidé la création d'une
mission commune d'information sur
l'accès aux documents administratifs aux
données publiques
donc madame bouche ou été désigné comme
rapporteur par la commission et moi
comme président nous avons nous avons
décidé bien sûr de procéder à des
auditions comme il se doit
et pour mesurer les progrès réalisés et
les difficultés rencontrées en matière
d'accès aux documents administratifs et
aux données publiques
les trois auditions auxquelles nous
procédons aujourd'hui s'inscrivent dans
ce premier volet de notre démarche
définir les attentes des différents
publics concernés en matière d'accès aux
documents administratifs et d'ouverture
des données publiques
alors c est des auditions sont ouvertes
au public à la presse et s'est diffusée
sur le
canal du sénat un compte rendu sommaire
en sera publié donc nous allons entendre
les représentants du conseil national du
numérique donc son président monsieur
benoît thieulin monsieur godefroy
beauvallet vice président monsieur
jean-baptiste soufron secrétaire général
madame mathilde bras rapportera loin
monsieur dimitri baquet rapporteur
adjoint stagiaires alors tout d'abord
une journée en avance on va vous
souhaiter un bon anniversaire puisque
c'est le 17 janvier décret du 17 janvier
que ça ne pouvait pas mieux tomber
je vous remercie d'avoir eu cette cette
élégance de nous de rappeler cette date
anniversaire effectivement voilà alors
je ne vais pas rappeler votre curriculum
vitae mais je pense que le mieux est de
vous donner tout de suite la parole pour
rappeler brièvement le rôle du conseil
national du numérique en particulier
dans le domaine des services publics et
davy citoyenne avant de présenter les
principaux constats et recommandations
du conseil en matière de diffusion et de
réutilisation des données publiques
le président merci
mais pardon vous organisés comme vous
oui bien sûr mais d'ailleurs vous allez
voir on va avoir une intervention assez
libre et puis de le plus possible
évidemment des échanges avec vous mais
maintiennent
enfin le sait 10h30 parce que l'on n'a
d'après d'autres auditions par un le les
échéances prévues
d'abord vous remercier monsieur le
président et puis messieurs dames et
rapporteur est membre de cette mission
d'information de nous avoir sollicité
sur un sujet évidemment qui nous est
particulièrement cher vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir évidemment que le mouvement
d'ouverture des données pour les
professionnels du numérique que nous
sommes au conseil national numérique
font évidemment partie des
problématiques sur lequel on a été
amenée déjà à se pencher sur lesquels
évidemment ont probablement on sera
amenée à retravailler dans l'est dans
les mois et dans les années qui viennent
juste peut-être pour rappel très
rapidement sur les missions du conseil
national du numérique et sur les travaux
qu'il a déjà qu'il a déjà mené le
conseil est une institution encore un
peu jeunes de la république qui avait
été créée par le précédent président
précédent pardon président de la
république et dont l'objet qui a été
finalement assez peu modifié après sa
réinstallation il ya maintenant presque
un an comme vous le soulignez tout à
l'heure monsieur le président vise tout
simplement à jouer un rôle un petit peu
d'interface entre les décideurs publics
au sens large du terme même si
évidemment nous travaillons beaucoup en
étant sollicités par des saisines par
les ministères et le monde du numérique
je pense qu'effectivement dans cette
phase de transition numérique dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons dans
laquelle évidemment une dynamique
d'innovation particulièrement forte fait
que ces problématiques évolue fortement
et qu'il est difficile de trouver des
interlocuteurs institutionnels stable on
va dire des corps intermédiaires un peu
institué qui suivrait toutes ces
évolutions et bien il avait été décidé
de créer spécifiquement un conseil qui
puisse accompagner au fond les décideurs
publics dans toutes ces réflexions
nous avons été réinstallé il ya
maintenant presque un an
nous sommes trente membres paritaire ça
n'est pas si fréquent dans les
institutions de la république pour le
rappeler ici et qui reflète je crois la
diversité de ce que représente
aujourd'hui le monde du numérique
évidemment le big business comme on dit
des opérateurs des grandes entreprises
françaises du numérique qui sont
représentés si je puis dire même si les
membres du conseil sont nommés intuiti
personae
mais au delà et c'est un point qui nous
a été cher dans la réinstallation du
conseil des universitaires des
représentants aussi de petites
entreprises de start-up d'associatifs de
think tank ou autre et je crois qu'on a
une certaine diversité qui fait que nos
avis en tout cas quand on les délibère
et quand on travaille sur un ensemble de
sujets s'enrichissent assez fortement
justement de ces différents types de
deux points de vue on a été amené depuis
maintenant presque une année à
travailler sur des sujets aussi divers
que la neutralité de l'internet la
fiscalité du numérique
l'inclusion numérique nous travaillons
en ce moment également sur la neutralité
des plateformes
nous allons probablement travailler
bientôt sur les questions de santé
bref le le le je dirais le périmètre
nous à un vent d'autan intervention
effectivement assez vaste et il nous a
été déjà amené à plusieurs reprises dans
un certain nombre de nos avis à nous
rapprocher au fond des problématiques de
données et de leur ouverture
ça peut éventuellement évidemment se
poser sur la question des données
publiques mais pas fort parfois pas pas
forcément de manière exclusive
je me souviens notamment avec godefroy
beauvallet qui est vice-président du
conseil précisément chargé des questions
liées aux services publics mais qui a
aussi eu la chance d'avoir à travailler
sur la question difficile de la
fiscalité du numérique savez que c'est
un des saisines qui nous a amenés à
organiser une concertation avec le
secteur et une de nos préconisations qui
me semblait innovantes et intéressante
était précisément sur la question de la
fiscalité en particulier grande
plateforme savaient qu'ils s'acquittent
assez peu de leurs impôts parce qu'il ya
des mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale
qui fonctionnent assez bien en france et
dans le reste de l'europe d'ailleurs une
de nos préconisations était précisément
de dire qu' il était difficile de faire
est de mettre en place des
fonctionnalités spécifiques fait
beaucoup d'effet par l'air c'est pas le
lieu ici de le détailler
mais en revanche que le fait de pousser
à davantage de transparence sur la
réalité de ce qu'ils étaient payés par
ces grandes plateformes dans un univers
dans lequel et pour lequel nous
d'ailleurs le concert on est évidemment
très conscient et très favorable à ça
dans ce mouvement de la gouvernance
ouverte je pourrais dire et dans lequel
les grandes plateformes sont quand même
toujours tributaire du choix que font au
quotidien les utilisateurs de d'y aller
et d'utiliser leurs services
et bien la transparence sur un certain
nombre de ces usages devient clés et
devient un élément extrêmement important
de la qualité de leur service et de la
satisfaction de leurs utilisateurs et
donc vous voyez que la sur un sur un
sujet assez éloignées comme la fiscalité
du numérique dans un champ différent de
celui pour lequel nous nous interroger
on retrouve en fait ces problématiques
de gouvernance ouverte qui pour nous est
clé et qui ouvre je pense vraiment une
nouvelle ère dans les relations que les
individus peuvent avoir avec le secteur
privé c'est l'exemple que je vous prends
mais également que les citoyens peuvent
avoir avec les institutions publiques et
ça c'est le sujet plus précisément sur
lequel vous nous interroger
alors il ya une problématique je pense a
dû largement déjà être poussés par les
auditions que vous avez commencé à
amener le pense qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans une forme de dialectique entre
cette gouvernance ouverte qui à mon avis
va engendrer de nouveaux types de
relations et probablement aussi des
phénomènes et des mouvements
d'amélioration des services qui peuvent
être extrêmement intéressant moi j'avais
travaillé et maintenant un deux en un ou
deux ans sur le sujet justement en
réfléchissant aux questions de l'olf de
réforme de l'état de réduction des
dépenses de du secteur public
en réfléchissant au fait qu'il est
probable que donnait parfois de la
visibilité à la société civile sur la
manière dont un certain nombre de
décisions de dépenses de programmes
peuvent être engagées et probablement
parfois un moyen en réalité d'améliorer
le service qui est rendu pour le faire
au fond monter en qualité et aussi
peut-être baissé en coûts et donc pour
nous cette ce phénomène et 7 ce
mouvement vers des gouvernance ouverte
évidemment peut-être la clé également
d'un certain nombre d'autres types de
préoccupation voilà ce que je pouvais
dire un petit peu en sûr là sur cette
partie je dirais de deux d'ouverture des
données
je pense qu'il faut aussi avoir en toile
de fond qu'un mouvement inverse vient
d'une certaine manière dialoguer avec
cette problématique et qui commencent à
émerger et évidemment c'est celle de ce
qu'on appelle les données en masse le
big data ou évidemment la yahoo s'il ya
évidemment là aussi une problématique de
d'externalités de création de nouveaux
types de services et donc d'entreprise
qui peut être extrêmement intéressant
mais qui commence à poser des questions
également je pense qu'il faut vraiment
avoir en toile de fond ce double
mouvement une nécessité d'aller vers dés
gouvernance qui soit davantage ouverte
et ça concerne évidemment le service
public mais également de se poser la
question de plus en plus de la
problématique un petit peu inverse qui
est que la multiplication de l'ouverture
d'un certain nombre de ces données la
capacité que l'on a
de les traiter en masse et de les
analyser avec énormément de finesse a
fortiori dans le contexte ne peut pas ne
pas en parler de la sphère snowden qui
va continuer je pense d'éveiller les
consciences de nos concitoyens et les
autres citoyens on à vis de l'union
européenne sur le fait que précisément
aujourd'hui dans un monde qui s'est
fortement numérisés et dans lequel une
grande partie de nos activités
quotidiennes trouve une trace dans ce
monde numérique il est évident qu'on
doit se poser aussi la question des
conséquences que cela peut avoir à titre
individuel et il faut donc trouver un
équilibre nouveau qui n'est pas celui de
l'ordre ancien un équilibre nouveau
entre cette volonté de continuer à
pousser l'administration de la sa tombe
d'entreprises vers ce mouvement de
gouvernance ouverte et en même temps de
se préoccuper de replacer le curseur de
manière équilibrée avec la problématique
de protection des données personnelles
et en particulier du droit à la vie
privée que les individus peuvent avoir
voilà pour moi les deux grosses
tendances sur lequel le conseil a pu
être amené depuis maintenant un peu
moins d'un an à réfléchir et qui va
nourrir je pense nos futurs travaux très
tenté de te donner un petit peu la
parole godefroy pour précisé attendre de
choses et puis je compléterai un petit
peu tout à l'heure monsieur le président
peut-être pour pour compléter
effectivement les remarques et la fin
sinon approfondir du moins aller plus
loin dans ce qu'a dit benoît donc
effectivement les deux sujets sont pour
moi d'une part les je dirais l'approché
économique de la données publiques et
d'autre part ceux qui demeurent
l'approchent
je dirais en liberté fondamentale et
puis en crédibilisation des politiques
publiques j'y reviendrai comme l'a dit
benoît les données c'est l'approché
économique
je prends les données dans le numérique
c'est comme l'air qu'on respire et on
peut se poser la question de qui doit
payer l'air qu'on respire ça serait
commode de pouvoir tarifé à la
respiration
mais c'est quand même assez compliqué
puis ça on sent bien que c'est gênant
les données c'est un peu les données
publiques c'est un peu du même ordre
le fait qu'on l'ait respire qu'on les
utilise quel dès que les administrations
d'abord et puis ensuite des acteurs en
est besoin ne veut pas dire qu'elles
doivent être système qu'on doive
systématiquement recherché le paiement
par l'utilisateur à l'utilisation
en d'autres termes c'est ce qu'on
appelle une externalités positives de
production et dès lors ça doit être
gérée dans dans la manière dont l'état
gère son actif immatériel typhi matériel
la notion de valorisation doit pas être
une notion de paiement à l'acte ou en
tout cas ces modèles nous paraissent
très malthusien par rapport à ce dont il
y aurait besoin notamment et c'est ce
que le remarquable rapport de monsieur
triet a notamment a indiqué si si on
veut valoriser ex ante et on est obligé
d'imaginer les business modèles qui
permettent cette valorisation en
d'autres termes on ignore tous les
business models que d'autres
valorisation autoriserait il faut donc
passer d'une logique ex ante et à une
logique de liberté une logique qui
permette l'expérimentation des décades
de réemploi et ça ça vient percuter deux
fronts une logique de valorisation je
dirais traditionnels donc ça c'est très
bien expliqué par par leur apport trop
jette et ça implique effectivement de se
donner pour la puissance publique un
objectif d'activation des données
publiques
plus qu'un objectif de valorisation au
sens immédiat pour cela on a
l'impression que les évolutions d'etalab
vont d'ailleurs dans ce sens là et à ce
titre j'imagine que dans les auditions
qui vont venir vous auditionnerait henri
verdier les équipes d'etalab et puis
plus largement sans doute celle du sg
map
parce que pour nous ça nous paraître
l'opérateur
je dirais essentiel et qui en plus a
récemment eu à reformuler
stratégiquement et dans le sens que j'ai
indiqué ses missions l'autre élément
etalab d'ailleurs y contribue aussi
c'est que dans cette valorisation l'état
l'épaule et vu la puissance publique
pourrait se donner un devoir
d'innovation puisqu'il s'agit d'inventer
des nouvelles manières d'utiliser ces
données des nouvelles manières de rendre
des services aux citoyens sur la base
des données publiques
alors le devoir d' innovation pourrait
être une manière pour les
administrations
je prends de voir d'innovation au fond
un peu commune comme une prolongation du
principe de mutabilité dans un dans un
dans un moment de boulversements si les
administrations ne se donne pas au tour
des données le devoir d' explorer
l'ensemble de ce qu'il est possible de
faire à partir de ce qu'elles produisent
ou l'ensemble de ce qu'il est possible
de faire en les utilisant
et bien d'autres le feront pour elle et
ça ne sera pas nécessairement au service
du modèle social que nous cherchons à
défendre c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose
que le rapport trop jette note aussi les
les données publiques elles servent à la
décision publique
et on se paye parfois un peu de mots en
disant qu'elles sont valorisés auprès
d'acteurs qui les paye parce qu'une
bonne partie de ces acteurs semble-t-il
ce sont des administrations est donc
enfin c'est sublime comptablement c'est
pas nécessairement utile budgétairement
pardonnerait un ancien directeur
financier de le voir comme ça
enfin on peut même aller plus loin parce
qu'aujourd'hui on parle d'une part de
donner d'autre part de documents
administratifs
aujourd'hui tout ça ça se ressemble
c'est ce que vous a dit je crois le
professeur chevallier et sous la notion
d'information publique on peut supprimer
des types de données et documents qui
aujourd'hui sont
son regarder différemment par par le
droit peut-être y at-il là une piste
pour vos travaux
d'autant plus que aujourd'hui il ya une
troisième 3ème type d'information
publique qui qui peut-être est
intéressant aussi qu'ils sont les
algorithmes de décision publique
aujourd'hui les la manière dont les
cotisations sociales sont reprises son
sont calculés dans les fiches de paye ce
sont des algorithmes et qui reposent sur
des documents publics les textes mais au
fond c'est l'algorithme qui prime c'est
l'algorithme qui fait le paiement donc
ça aussi ce sont des choses ce sont des
informations publiques qui pourraient
gagner à être rendus disponibles sous
une forme plus algorithmique et pas
simplement sous la forme de texte
peut-être tu veux redire quelques mots
sur cet aspect là avant que je passe le
haut point qui m'est cher sur la
crédibilité des politiques publiques
justes pour confirmer à l'ensemble du
conseil a vraiment énormément apprécié
le rapport projette donc je voulais
juste leur souligné et effectivement je
pense qu'il ya une orientation qui était
déjà été données par le précédent
gouvernement
je pense a été porté un cran plus loin
par la nouvelle équipe des tables qui me
semble vraiment à encourager et
effectivement les travaux de votre sur
votre rapport devrait devrait
certainement un money list enrichir je
pense de les auditionner j'ai regardé et
m'a pas semblé que vous les aviez encore
prévu mais je me s'est peut être trompé
mais vraiment je vous y encourage
parce que ce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
initié encore récemment s'ils ont lancé
leur nouveau site internet vraiment sur
un mode très collaboratif très ouvert je
pense que la france est vraiment en
train de reprendre la tête de ce moment
là au niveau international c'est quelque
chose de bien alors justement peut-être
pour prendre quelques exemples concrets
de suggestions en fait dans dans ce
champ de l'ouverture des données
publiques savait que la france a été
très pionnière en 1978 avec la création
de la cnil c'est probablement le premier
pays c'est discuté avec la suède ou la
norvège mais globalement c'est le
premier grand pays occidental
à s'être dotée d'une telle institution
la france a vraiment innover et dans le
champ des libertés est dans le champ
innovants à l'époque de ce qu'on
appelait l'informatique en revanche
quasiment la même année a été institué
la cada et sur la cadart pour le coup je
pense que la france est restée
probablement un peu timide
elle s'est d'abord inspiré avec retard
de ce qui avait été instituée aux états
unis notamment vous savez le fameux
freedom of information act qui a été
votée par le congrès et le sénat en 1966
et qui malgré les révisions législatives
qui ont eu lieu en france depuis la
création de la cada continue quand même
d'être assez en deçà de ses consoeurs
américaines mais aussi anglaise et si on
regarde de manière générale au sein de
l'union européenne la france n'est quand
même pas particulier en pointe dans ce
domaine là je pense qu'il ya un vrai
sujet à ce qu' on puisse faire plus que
toi l'été ce qui a été fait jusque là
mais peut-être un tout petit peu changé
de paradigme et d'une certaine manière
de ce point de vue là j'aurais tendance
à m'inspirer des récents revirements qui
ont été décidées par ce gouvernement
notamment sur le silence de
l'administration qui ne vaut plus refuge
mais au contraire acceptation et bien
j'aurais tendance à faire un parallèle
au fond sur ce revirement qui me semble
avoir marqué un changement dans
l'administration française
pardon oui c'est vrai vous avez raison
monsieur le président c'est vrai c'est à
craindre mais du coup c'est vrai que
j'aurais tendance à souhaiter peut-être
dans mes rêves les plus fous à ce que le
parlement se saisisse justement à quelle
occasion c'est à vous de le décider ou
au gouvernement mais en tout cas de
faire en sorte que peut-être que
l'exception de l'accès aux données qui
est pourtant aujourd'hui finalement ce
qui est inscrit dans la loi skis
guide les procédures de la cada soit
inversée et que finalement la règle soit
l'accès et que devienne l'exception au
fond de ne pas avoir accès je pense
qu'il ya vraiment un revirement affaire
est d'une certaine manière probablement
à faire en sorte que la france la hausse
y retrouve dans cette nouvelle ère de
gouvernance ouverte plutôt la tête comme
elle l'avait fait très bien à l'occasion
de cette grande loi de 1978 qui
demandera par ailleurs certainement à
être à être réaménagé vous savez que
récemment le conseil national numérique
s'est autosaisie à l'occasion du débat
d'ailleurs largement enrichie ou
provoquées par le sénat sur la loi de
programmation militaire son article 13
devenu articles 20 et que notre approche
mesurée je crois mais quand même
interpellante a justement visé a rappelé
qu'il y avait un besoin d'avoir une
approche globale sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets et que une loi sur les libertés
ou plus généralement sur la
transformation numérique qui viendraient
revisiter un certain nombre de ces
problématiques la chose qui n'a
quasiment pas été fait en france depuis
cette grande loi qui a été la loi sur la
confiance dans l'économie numérique en
2004 de mémoire donc on arrive quasiment
à 10 ans à son anniversaire
eh bien je pense qu'on devrait
effectivement en tout cas c'est ce qu'a
souhaité et ce qu'a fait en
s'autosaisissant le conseil national
numérique en un an sans que nous allions
travailler sur une grande concertation
sur cette question de la transformation
numérique qui touchent évidemment à des
libertés et à de nouveaux types de droit
également et juste pour préciser un tout
petit peu sur cette saisine parce qu'au
conseil on a vraiment ce souci et je
pense qu'il va évidemment irrigué
également vos travaux d'avoir une vision
je dirais de manière systématique un peu
à trois étages il ya évidemment un
certain nombre de choses qui doivent
être décidées dans le cadre national et
la loi doit se saisir à nouveau de ces
sujets là mais également réfléchir et
injecté au niveau européen
ces nouvelles problématiques vous savez
qu'il y à une directive ou un règlement
européen qui est un petit peu encalminé
depuis quelques temps
sur la question des données personnelles
nous poussons beaucoup au conseil
national numérique nous l'avons dit au
premier ministre que nous avons eu
l'honneur de rencontrer lundi dernier
qu'il y avait un enjeu à ce que la
france poussent la future commission
européenne à remettre d'une certaine
manière le sujet danser dans ces
discussions et a poussé cette directive
6 ou ce règlement pardon si ça n'avait
pas été fait d'ici là et enfin troisième
étage il faudra probablement un jour que
un traité international viennent
renforcer l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
je pense que ça devrait probablement
être discuté dans vos travaux n'y a pas
de raison à ce que dans ce grand
mouvement de gouvernance ouverte qui
concerne au fond toute la planète qui
c'est qui est enfin en train de changer
profondément nos sociétés profondément
les entreprises dans l'âme à nantes elle
travaille il faut quand même se souvenir
qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui vont
être qu'ils ont déjà été mais qui vont
être confrontés à cette question de
données sensibles
la sphère snowden devrait avec beaucoup
de prudence et d'humilité interpeller
les entreprises françaises ou autre
d'ailleurs sur le fait que si des
organismes aussi sécurisé que la haine
et sait où la cia peuvent être
confrontés parfois à des fuites sur des
données extrêmement sensible il est fort
à parier ressentons d'entreprises qui
peuvent parfois être assise son centre
de données sensibles seront confrontés à
ces dispositions à ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que ce mouvement il est
général il concerne l'administration
bien sûr et je vous félicite de vous
êtes saisis de ce sujet mais il faudra
aussi poser cette question y compris au
secteur privé bref ce mouvement est en
général il serait intéressant et c'est
là dessus que le conseil national
numérique va orienter ses travaux dans
les mois qui viennent dans cette
concertation a poussé également à ce
qu'un traité international se saisisse
de ces sujets on pourrait rêver d'une
espèce de loi 78 revisité mais à
l'échelle internationale en tout cas
vous savez quelles initiatives ont été
prises par le brésil et par l'allemagne
la france devrait s'honorerait elle
aussi à prendre sinon la tête de ce
mouvement là en tout cas à y contribuer
en y apportant sa pierre
donc voilà noon ou nounou
nous sommes extrêmement favorable encore
une fois au conseil national numérique à
ce que la cada la loi qui la gouvernent
puisse inspirer d'un mécanisme de tifos
ya écueil à cette inversion du paradigme
qui puisse qui puisse être relancé
votre frange torrent la parole pour
continuer à approfondir les prévisions
sur lesquelles tu es très impliqués
n'ont peut-être simple effectivement à
nouveau pour pour prolonger ce que dit
benoît je voudrais là la nécessité de
cette inversion de paradigme est de
passer à une une liberté des données des
informations publiques par défaut n'est
pas simplement une affaire de progrès
historique de l'ouverture des sociétés
je crois que c'est une nécessité pour la
crédibilité des politiques publiques et
de la décision administrative qui en
découlent aujourd'hui je voudrais en
prendre deux exemples la récente
polémique autour des chiffres du chômage
et des annonces de l'anpe qui suit
paraît-il à des difficultés d'un
opérateur a conduit à un yoyo des
chiffres du chômage seul yoyo se paye de
crédibilité pour l'ensemble des acteurs
qui ont été pris dans cette pole est
dans cette controverse et la confiance
dans l'expression des administrations et
des ministres et du gouvernement
et puis des contrôleurs sur ces sujets
est une des bases de la démocratie au
fond parce que sinon on se retrouve dans
une situation où on a plus confiance sur
la nature de la réalité et ça ça devient
compliqué de faire du consensus donc
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans un
exercice je dirai simplement humaniste
ont trait aussi dans la défense des
capacités d'action aujourd'hui des des
instances politiques p puis les publics
et politiques
et puis deuxième exemple tout récent une
polémique entre l'ambassadeur de france
en grande bretagne et le ministre
de la santé par voie de presse se
déroule autour de l'efficacité ou non
des dispositifs d'assurance santé en
france et en grande-bretagne et les uns
et les autres de dire que c'est mieux
chez eux ce qui est bien normal mais du
coup on commence à regarder
est-ce que c'est crédible et vous savez
quel est le mouvement des facs checkers
et et puis là le gouvernement le pays
qui est capable d'aligner le plus de
données ouvertes de donner le plus de
crédibilité à sa position
au fond on gagne la polémique et c'est
pas toujours le gouvernement français
donc je crois que à de la fois pour la
crédibilité interne vis-à-vis des
citoyens et pour la réputation la
crédibilité externe de la france
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
on est aujourd'hui pas simplement dans
quelque chose qui serait bien d'avoir
mais dans une nécessité et ça fait
partie du rang du pays d'avoir une
politique aujourd'hui ambitieuse dans ce
domaine je voudrais juste un tout petit
peu de non pas du tout d'enfoncer le
clou au contraire je nuancerais pâte et
propose la tendance plutôt aller est
confirmée avec force
j'ai une conviction personnelle assez
forte
c'est que vos multiples raisons qu'il
faut pas qu'il n'est pas opportun de
d'élaborer ici on vit quand même une
forme de dégradation du débat public et
d'une forme de scepticisme qui quand
même sens par énormément de nos
concitoyens je pense que je peux donner
plusieurs exemples récents où
j'entendais des gens à la télévision m
qui reste quand même la plateforme du
débat public la plus massivement suivi
beaucoup de commentateurs ou de
personnalités disait mais finalement les
chiffres on leur fait dire en effet rien
dit on leur fait dire ce que l'on veut
et donc beaucoup de suspicion beaucoup
plus beaucoup de scepticisme autour
finalement d'un centre de ces données et
c'est pour ça que je voulais vraiment
insister je crois que le fait d'être
capable de pouvoir à nouveau d'une
certaine manière disposer de données
fiables vérifié par la société par des
think tanks par des contre-pouvoirs par
des ong
ça permettrait en réalité de
reconstruire les bases qui me semble
absolument nécessaire du débat public en
démocratie et donc vous voyez que
évidemment qu'il ya des enjeux de
liberté qu'il ya des enjeux je dirais
humaniste et évidemment qu'il ya des
enjeux économiques
extraits
man puissant mais je vous dirais il ya
un enjeu démocratique tout simplement et
qui n'est pas pour retrouver je ne sais
quel âge d'or c'est tout simplement que
aujourd'hui si on veut reconstruire
davantage de liens et de confiance entre
les représenter et les représentants et
bien je pense que d'une certaine manière
renforcer les bases du débat public me
semble important et là dessus les
données parce qu'elles sont un des
éléments un des matériaux du débat
public
ça me semble absolument clé au fond il
pour conclure sur sa ce qui est
redéfinie par le numérique est ce qu il
redéfinit par le moment c'est la
fiabilité
comment construit ton la fiabilité
aujourd'hui on sait que les institutions
ne sont plus on peut le regretter mais
regardez comme naturellement fiable il
suffit de regarder les enquêtes
d'opinion sur le sujet les il ya un
relais qui est les grandes plateformes
c'est à dire l'opinion agrégés par les
grandes plateformes numériques
en même temps on voit que elle même soit
parce qu'elles monétise soit parce que
les gens qui ont des enjeux de
réputation viennent y expliquer pourquoi
leur réputation doit être ce qu'elle
doit être
ces grandes plateformes probablement
ceux ne suffiront pas à prendre le
relais donc comment dans le numérique
reconstruire de la fiabilité
probablement par la vérifiabilité et
donc le fait que le citoyen des think
tanks des ddd facture' émergents les
médias puissent aller de liens
hypertextes en lien hypertexte danalyse
en analyse de publications d'algorithmes
en publications d'algorithmes d'open
source de d'open source ification enfin
d'autres déplacements en logiciels
libres 2 des outils de calcul d'un
certain nombre de choses dans l'état
c'est ça aujourd'hui la vérifiabilité
j'en prends deux exemples ça veut
simplement pour aussi le pointé le rôle
du monde de la recherche compte
thomas piketty par exemple veut faire
bouger le débat sur la fiscalité il
produit un site qui permet de simuler
l'impôt ce site au fond est probablement
le duplicata un site qui existe à
l'intérieur du ministère des finances
est ce que le ministère des finances
publiques à il a été refait c'est pas il
n'y a pas de problème de propriété
intellectuelle
ce n'est pas une fille mais s'est on se
bat on oblige finalement la recherche à
reproduire un modèle qui existe est ce
qui ne serait pas tout à fait
intéressant qu'un seul modèle existe
qu'il soit ouvert et qu' ils soient
vérifiées et qu'il soit utilisé par les
uns et par les autres après tout
normalement il n'a pas de
caractéristiques politicienne dans ce
modèle pour en prendre cet exemple ça ça
repose sur une changement de paradigme
au fond de la manière dont l'état
approche c'est donner ces informations
mais il aurait probablement aujourd'hui
à en bénéficier à la fois dans
l'efficacité
il ya tout à parier que le modèle serait
meilleur et en même temps dans l'eau
possibilité finalement dans dans le
débat public des informations qui en
découlent
donc voilà le voilà le genre de choses
je précise d'ailleurs à ce propos que
les chercheurs
souvent aujourd'hui sont embêtés par
l'absence de données le manque de
données la difficulté à accéder aux
données en france pour ne prendre et ça
aussi c'est un enjeu de crédibilité
pourquoi de très nombreux articles
d'économies portent sur le cas américain
et bien parce que les données
américaines sont disponibles et donc si
les données ne sont pas disponibles et
des déserts des français des chercheurs
français sont bien obligés de travailler
sur le cas américain et pas sur le cas
français parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
donner en france alors qu'elles sont
accessibles sur internet aux etats-unis
la situation évolue mais moins vite
qu'on ne pourrait l'espérer et visite
est même si c'est des choses évidentes
pour tous les experts qui travaillent
sur les questions des données évidemment
la simple ouverture des données ne
suffit pas loin de là mais la question
de leur bonne structuration dans des
formats ouverts réutilisables et plus
encore la stabilité la stabilité de la
structuration de ces données est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important
le hasard a voulu qu'il ya quelques mois
j'ai rencontré un chercheur qui met en
place un observatoire jia pas lequel
parce que je veux pas le mettre en
difficulté
mais un observatoire à partir des
données de l'insee et qui me disait que
depuis que l'insee avait vu qu'il
récupère s est donné pour en faire un
croisement original et pour en tirer des
éléments d analyse différents il avait
remarqué que tous les maux tous les six
mois
ce jeu de données était modifiée
compliquant d'autant le travail que lui
pouvait faire pour moi c'est typique
voilà il faut pas se contenter de
demander à ce que les administrations
pour ce cas-là ouvrent leurs données
mais faut bien se préoccuper ray faut
bien se préoccuper pardon de la bonne
structuration de ces données il ya des
api notamment mais aussi de la stabilité
de ses api de cette structuration sans
quoi on peut continuer d'avoir un droit
théorique d'accès à ces données et dans
la pratique en réalité compliquer le
travail de l'écosystème ça me fait une
transition d'ailleurs peut-être pour
conclure avant que vous ne posiez
peut-être un certain nombre de questions
le mot n'a pas encore été trop prononcé
à part par godefroy qui parlait tout à
l'heure de plateformes
je pense que un des éléments importants
aujourd'hui de révolution dans
l'économie et même au delà
c'est la question au fond d'eux
sage vers une économie de plus en plus
de plateformes je reviendrai pas ici sur
la définition de ce que c'est mais vous
savez que les états unis les américains
parlent beaucoup ont décliné au fond ce
concept en disant qu' évidemment ça
touchait également un gouvernement il
parle de government has the platform ça
veut dire quoi mais ça veut dire que de
plus en plus un état ne va plus
simplement rendre directement des
services à ses concitoyens mais va de
plus en plus être un facilitateur va
mettre aux dispositions un certain
nombre de données ou de services qui
ensuite vont être ré approprier par la
société par des entreprises par des
associations qui elles mêmes vont
réinventer derrière un certain nombre de
ces services est évidemment la matière
qui permet le développement de ce
nouveau type de service parfois de
service public
même si c'est rendu par des personnes
privées par des associations et bien
repose pour l'essentiel sur cette
matière qu'elle a données publiques donc
on voit bien qu'on est si on souhaite
vraiment à ce que dit et de l'innovation
dans les services publics
ouvrir le satin derrière une nouvelle
ère beaucoup plus collaborative pas
forcément dans le service marchand
j'insiste sur ce point mais qui
permettent justement à l'émergence de
nouveaux types de services dans lequel
il ya une collaboration une coopération
entre la société civile et la puissance
publique ça me semble ça me semble un
point absolument clé et je vous dirais
que on ne peut donc que se réjouir de
voir par exemple je n'en ai juste cet
exemple qui est très parlant de voir la
manière dont par exemple ign a pu
modifier ses ambitions et ses objectifs
puisque après avoir hésité un certain
nombre d'années pour des raisons qu'on
peut comprendre d'ailleurs qu'ils
n'étaient pas tout est légitime loin de
là mais aujourd'hui d'avoir pris
conscience que le rapprochement par
exemple avec le mouvement
d'openstreetmap était évidemment un
choix politique et stratégique
absolument majeur et le conseil l'a
serrée numérique ne peut que souhaiter
une certaine manière la systématisation
la généralisation de ce genre de
démarches auprès d'un certain nombre
d'autres types d'acteurs publics voilà
moi c'est là dessus que je conclurai et
puis avant de vous les de vous donner
évidemment la parole pour nous poser des
questions si vous en avez et peut-être à
toi godefroy de conclure dire un mot si
tu avais quelque chose à ajouter
la conclusion est brillant si tu y es
dans les exemples de information n'est
pas comprise ou les des données alors
c'est pas tant dans le domaine de la
justice et de la sécurité
alors là c'est même c'est étonnant les
polémiques permanentes sur parce qu'on a
mais là je crois que ça vient aussi que
venez à la base des données sont pas
homogènes et c'est donc on
quant à la justice on sait très bien là
la capacité normes du ministère de la
justice avoir un bon outil statistique
ou informatique même d'ailleurs je peux
m je pense que c'est une il ya une bonne
illustration
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de mouvements
là pas seulement en france mais aussi à
l'international de mise en cartographie
de données de sécurité de données de
délinquance ou de choses comme ça
les phalanges 'crime map les fameuses
fait beaucoup les choux gras aux états
unis notamment
voilà avec l'idée que du coup on peut
vérifier à la fois ce qui se passe en
temps réel ou presque et en même temps
la valeur lié l'accord et les la
valorisation d'un emplacement avec la
délinquance alors les études d'usagés
sur les crânes maps sont assez
intéressante parce que elles tendent à
montrer que au fond les gens adoptent le
niveau de zoom dans la carte qui
correspond à leur sentiment d'insécurité
a priori en d'autres termes quelle que
soit votre sentiment de sécurité ou
d'insécurité vous trouverez à le
confirmer
en regardant la crown map haut à la
bonne échelle
puisqu'il ya eu 20 voix là et ceci est
alors si je suis je suis je si je monte
face jeu si je porte ce point à votre
attention c'est parce que quand une
c'est important du coup pour la
puissance publique quand elle met à
disposition les données de regarder
quels en sont les effets puis d'avoir
une politique en la matière c'est à dire
de contribuer activement à
l'interprétation de ces données
elle doit évidemment pas en avoir le
monopole
mais elle ne doit pas non plus s'en
désengager on n'est pas dans une logique
le government as the platform c'est pas
le government intermédié par des acteurs
soient privés enfin soient économiques
soient politiques et donc il y a quelque
chose auquel il faut faire attention ça
permet aussi aux à la puissance publique
aux administrations de progresser dans
leur compréhension et ça implique enfin
il ya une forme de devoir de formation
des citoyens des d'information et de
formation qui permet et ça peut aussi
être transitif à travers les conditions
d'utilisation des données de ne pas je
dirais servir des objectifs qui pourrait
être contre-productif ou dommageable à
la cohésion sociale rapporte madame
messieurs merci de votre votre
intervention
moi j'aurai deux questions sur deux
plans assez différent que pensez vous
que nous devrions faire pour réduire la
fracture alors elle est culturelle elle
est très générationnel entre eux pour
aller vite ceux qui sont conscients des
enjeux que vous évoquez voilà qui qui
ont cette intuition qu'il ya cette
question et tous ceux qui ne comprennent
même pas le sujet donc je vais vous
donner un exemple moi depuis que je suis
rapporteur de cette mission je pourrais
ne faire que ça je suis sollicité par
des associations par des établissements
scolaires je vais demain au moment où il
ya les classes prépas qui ont demandé à
ce qu'on fasse une conférence etc
donc d'un côté il ya une demande qui
vient plus tôt il faut être clair des
jeunes qui maîtrise des nouvelles
technologies qui suis en train de voir
qu'on est en train de changer de société
et qui veulent en discuter qui veulent
en débattre et puis on va dire d'un
autre côté pour des raisons qu'on
comprend bien peut-être d'âge de
formation n'est pas très fort en culture
scientifique en france on va dire toute
une partie de la population qui ne
voient pas le débat alors c'est
peut-être mon côté malicieux qui me fait
dire ça mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'on
est à un carrefour sociétale à peu près
la même chose avec un débat qui n'a pas
eu lieu et que je ne vais pas refaire
ici au moment où on a fait en france le
choix du nucléaire qui avait deux
positions possibilité pour y en a une
qui a été choisi
et bien là on est à la veille de ce type
de changement de société et pourtant ça
passionne certains et on va dire c'est
un sujet qui laisse de marbre tout seul
et on peut les comprendre qu'ils ne
voient même pas qu'un sujet se pose donc
si vous aviez des idées sur comment on
pourrait faire en sorte que les ces deux
catégories de population se rencontrent
à mon avis c'est un sujet majeur
deuxième question que je vais vous poser
et là aussi la réponse interpelle je
faisais hier soir au musée des
beaux-arts d'angers une conférence sur
la question du retour des oeuvres d'art
spoliée et à la fin de la réunion où il
y avait beaucoup de monde attendait un
monsieur très âgé me disant oui vous
vous intéressez aux données publiques
etc
mais il m'a regardé et m'a dit mais si
pendant l'occupation
on avait eu toutes les technologies dont
vous faites la promotion maintenant ça
aurait été bien pire et je vous avoue
que pendant quelques instants puis
d'écouter ont fait pas l'histoire il
faut pas faire d' anachronisme
mais quelque part ça remarque m'a semblé
extrêmement fondé de dire que là nous
songeons au meilleur des mondes mais
quelles sont les questions que nous nous
posons sur et si et si la démocratie
avait des soucis donc je pense que sur
ces deux questions vous avez peut-être
réfléchi où je pense que c'est un vrai
débat qui se pose est peut-être que les
collègues ont aussi des questions à
poser à vous toucher un sujet
fondamental au palis du nucléaire je
pense qu'effectivement l'importance de
l'enjeu se situe à peu près au même
niveau donc vous avez entièrement raison
madame je peux que souscrire à ce que
vous avez dit ensuite à mon avis le
sujet et les réponses sont multiples
dans ce que vous poussiez d'abord vous
le soulignez il ya un sujet en france je
crois je partage votre constat de défaut
de culture scientifique qui récent qui
récents la france a été pendant très
longtemps un pays d'ingénieurs
c'est le pays de jules verne des
inventions c'est que la france était le
premier pays des poseurs de brevets
d'invention à la fin du 19e siècle
donc la france a une grande tradition
d'inventeurs une grande tradition
d'ingénieurs et de scientifiques mais
c'est vrai que depuis une quarantaine
une cinquantaine d'années ce lien c'est
un peu distendues
et on le voit d'ailleurs dans la
désaffection des vocations scientifiques
au conseil national d'ailleurs
va être amené à travailler là dessus
avec le ministère de l'éducation
nationale car c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe énormément j'étais en israël
avec le présent de répliques a
maintenant trois mois il était frappé
par ce que nous ont dit nos
interlocuteurs israéliens
ils ont en l'espace de quinze ans il ya
15 ans ils ont pris des décisions dont
on peut changer ces choses là et ils ont
multiplié par 8 ses vocations
scientifiques donc à un sujet vous avez
raison de vocation ensuite de manière
peut-être un peu plus pointilliste au
delà de ça je ne peux pas ne pas poser
la question il ya un fameux article dans
le monde récemment d'une forme de
déconnexion de nos élites qui n'est pas
que public
cette déconnexion en général alors elle
pourrait être analysée sous un angle qui
nous éloigne du sujet d'une plus grande
difficulté dans notre pays qu'ailleurs a
renouvelé ses élites et a passé la main
au fond à des générations plus jeunes
c'est un sujet beaucoup plus large mais
je vous dirai comment monsieur le
président non bien sûr mais mais je
pense pas vraiment je vous savez d'abord
y ait des élections mais je pense pas
tant au parlement je trouve ça ce n'est
pas du tout un discours anti générations
âgées loin de là je pense qu'on a besoin
de sagesse on a besoin d'expérience loin
de là moi de penser le contraire
en revanche je pense qu'il faut de la
diversité et c'est vrai que dans la
formation de nos élites actuellement je
pense évidemment à la haute fonction
publique mais pas que dans les grandes
entreprises c'est pareil il ya
probablement eu trop longtemps un défaut
d'enseignement scientifique je pense que
c'est un vrai sujet que de réfléchir à
comment est-ce que à l'ena ou ailleurs
on ré enseigne fortement de la culture
scientifique et l'ensemble des
problématiques dont on vient de parler
ça c'est pour les élites
mais y'a pas que les élites vous parliez
vous même vous disiez vous souligner le
fait que ça ne préoccupait pas toute la
population alors que même dans le petit
univers numérique dont on est dans un
certain nombre de personnes que vous
allez auditionné après nous sont les
problématiques pour elle absolument
stratégique est absolument majeur
d'abord j'ai tendance à penser que ça
change
c'est à dire que je peux pas ne pas
reparler de la sphère snowden qui est
une déflagration majeure et dont je
pense que l'on doit mesurer les
conséquences dans l'opinion publique qui
ne sont pas mesurables aujourd'hui mais
qui vont l'être et qui pose la question
de la confiance
absolument clé l'économie numérique doit
et ne pourra se développer que si elle
repose sur de la confiance et de la
durabilité durabilité ce n'est pas le
sujet aujourd'hui mais sachez que ça
intéresse le conseil national numérique
il ya aujourd'hui des mécaniques qui
sous-tendent l'économie numérique qui
sont loin d'être durable on a évoqué
tout à l'heure la fiscalité
c'en est un mais elle a d'autres mais
reposons nous juste la question de
savoir pourquoi est ce que une partie de
la population ne devrait pas
progressivement prendre conscience de ça
moi j'ai la conviction contraire je suis
profondément convaincu que les débats
liés justement à ces problématiques
d'usagé de donner que tous les français
vont avoir de plus en plus dans leur vie
quotidienne encore une fois les gens
aujourd'hui ont dans leur poche un
ordinateur qui suit quasiment en temps
réel
énormément de leurs activités et ça ne
peut que aller de manière croissante
cette confiance là et les clés et il
faut donc à mon avis ne pas du tout
pensé que l'opinion ne sera pas
travailler par ces problématiques là je
pense qu'encore une fois les
conséquences de la ferso net qui n'est
qu'un qu'un symbole d'une certaine
manière que la question de la confiance
va être posée et qu'il va falloir la
résoudre y répondre
donc évidemment vous avez raison
aujourd'hui la totalité la population ne
se sent pas concernée je pense que ce
jeu ces choses là vont évoluer au delà
de ça on a été amené au conseil national
numérique a travaillé avec valérie
peugeot qui est vice présidente et qui a
commis je crois parce que c'est plutôt
la manière dont je dirais la société les
institutions ont accueilli ce rapport je
crois a commis un rapport sur
l'inclusion numérique qui fera date et
là dedans a été poussée notamment le
concept de littératie numérique savait
qu'on compte ce bernard stiegler quinta
grande chercheurs parmi les membres du
conseil national numérique et bernard
stiegler nous dit souvent
il nous a fait évoluer moi je croyais
qu'on vivait simplement un changement de
civilisation avec le numérique ce qui
est déjà pas mal vous me dire est une
espèce de révolution aussi importante
que la révolution industrielle plus la
révolution de l'imprimerie mais tous
assurent à peine une ou deux générations
les mutations en cours sont absolument
majeur bastille clair et nous dit c'est
encore plus que ça ils nous disent cette
équipe ça équivaut quasiment à l'échelle
de l'humanité au passage de la culture
orale à la culture écrite
vous voyez les transformations à
l'oeuvre et les changements que ça va
évidemment engendrer d'où l'idée de
littératie numérique a été poussé dans
ce rapport et qui vise justement à poser
cette question finalement de l'ensemble
des clés de connaissance de nouveaux
types d' usage de réflexion que l'on
doit avoir sur ses usages et qui est
posée à toute la société et qui a essayé
de battre en brèche une idée que
certains pouvaient avoir dans le monde
du numérique encore quelques années j'en
faisais partie d'ailleurs à penser que
ce que l'on appelle outre atlantique
outre manche les digital natives ville
certaine manière
l'émergence de cette nouvelle génération
qui sera menée avec le numérique qui en
aura pratiqué les grands usage dès son
plus jeune âge et bien mécaniquement se
trouverait conscientiser et parfaitement
à l'aise dans ce monde là je crois que
c'est tout le contraire aujourd'hui
c'est en tout cas ce que le rapport sur
l'inclusion numérique qui avait été
menée par valérie peugeot essaie de
montrer c'est qu'il ne faut pas attendre
des digital natives une espèce de
génération spontanée qui lui ferait
aborder l'ensemble des problématiques du
numérique de manière naturelle c'est
évidemment et vous avez raison madame la
rapporteuse de poser cette question
c'est éminemment plus compliqué que ça
et donc ne peut pas vous résumer
l'ensemble des dispositions qui ont été
poussés dans ce rapport mais il est
évident que la question de
l'enseignement nous paraît absolument
clé et je vous dirais deux pistes qui me
semble devoir être absolument disjointes
la question de la réflexion sur l' usage
est absolument clé faire réfléchir les
élèves à ces jeunes aux conséquences que
peuvent avoir leur usage au quotidien
des médias sociaux demain des objets
connectés et c est quelque chose
d'important vous savez
on est obligé de prendre ses références
parce que elle est forte il ya déjà
quelques années barack obama a fait une
vidéo
alors je demande parce que forcément le
présent la pluie française se met à
faire une vidéo à l'intention de
l'ensemble des élèves de ce pays mais
c'est pour vous donner le niveau de
conscience aux états unis de ces
problématiques là puisque c'est la
maison blanche qui intervient café une
vidéo pour dire et rappeler aux enfants
aux élèves je crois que c'était dans
l'école primaire qu'il fallait qu'il
fasse attention et que ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire en ligne pourrait être
conservé longtemps et parfois joué
contre eux et contre leur carrière
contre leur réputation
donc c'est pour dire que la question de
l' usage me semble absolument clé et oui
il faut c'est des choses qu'on pousse
son travail en ce moment avec les
ministres à l'éducation nationale oui il
va falloir de plus en plus qu'il y ait
un enseignement et une réflexion autour
de ces usages et pour approfondir ce que
disait godefroy et que aussi un je
dirais un tropisme qu'on a beaucoup en
scène nationale numérique et que forme
très bien les américains qui dit
enseignements dits recherche et en
france on ne pense pas assez le
numérique il faut qu'ils aient plus de
chercheurs il faut qu'ils aient plus de
chair il faut qu'il y ait plus de
travaux plus d'appels à projets qui
permettent à l'université au monde
académique français de se saisir de ces
sujets-là de les objective et sinon on
est toujours dans les débats est ce que
jeux vidéo et plus violents est ce que
ça encourage la violence chez les
enfants ou pas chacun un avis n'a
absolument aucun intérêt et les débats
sont médiocres
si on veut avoir des débats publics qui
sont intéressants et efficace il faut
qu'on a montré des bas il ya un travail
d'objectivation de diagnostic de pistes
d'évolution soient poussés par la
recherche et je pense que ça c'est des
choses qui sont importantes
ça c'est pour les usages mais je veux
dire il ya un autre volet qui rejoint la
question de la littératie qui rejoint la
question de la culture numérique
on ne peut pas dans ce monde numérique
qui émergent et quand enfin dévorer le
monde analogique les deux sont
totalement imbriqués il ya plus de
séparation le numérique n'est plus un
secteur on a coutume de dire au conseil
national du numérique il instille sa
dimension dans tous les secteurs de
l'économie dans tous les secteurs de
notre vie sociale
on ne peut pas aborder ce monde
numérique sans en comprendre les
fondamentaux et là je ne parle pas de
l'usaj je parle du code du code
informatique
de la même manière que l'école de jules
ferry dans un contexte construction
d'une économie 1
striée elle a enseigné les bases de la
mécanique puis de l'électricité etc etc
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui on doit
enseigner à ses taux je ne sais pas où
ça c'est à des débats et les chercheurs
de le dire c'est pas à nous par à moi en
tout cas
mais en revanche il me paraît évident
qu'il faut enseigner le code la
programmation les notions de base assez
tôt dans le système éducatif français
ça me semble une en tension majeure et
vous voyez que pour ne rester que sur
ceux du plus tôt la madame la
rapporteuse je pense que la réflexion
sur les usages et l'enseignement de ces
usages et les bases de ce que c'est que
la programmation dans un monde qui
devient fortement numérique pour moi
répondre un petit peu à cette
problématique là tu veux être complétés
puis maintenant répondre à la seconde de
la seconde question oui alors simplement
pour eux effectivement complété je pense
qu'ils osent là de l'aspect
générationnel je pense qu'en france on
n'aime séparer le monde entre sachant et
non sachant sur un sujet et sur le
nucléaire comme sur le numérique sans
doute il faut avoir en tête que sur le
numérique nous ne sommes pas dans un
rattrapage
nous sommes dans une invention et 80%
des fonctions et des usages du numérique
+ 10 91 arrive l'essentiel reste encore
à inventer
dès lors d'abord nous sommes tous
dépassés à chaque instant et je crois
que 20 mois en tout cas le peux
témoigner que je suis dépassée chaque
matin mais que chaque matin je continue
d'apprendre et c'est cette attitude qui
permettent de d'être en permanence de
s'adapter de créer de d'imaginer le
numérique
parce que le deuxième point puisque le
numérique reste largement inventées il
n'y a pas de de forme de fatalité qui
ferait qu' il détruirait nos valeurs nos
pratiques etc
c'est au contraire l'occasion de les
prolonger de les après il n'y a pas
qu'un numérique
il y en a plusieurs et si nous ne
défendons pas le nôtre nous nous
pourrons imposer celui d'autres si nous
ne contribueront pas à l'inventer il
sera inventé pour nous et ça je crois
que c'est ça le message et ce message il
s'adresse je dirais
aux élites comme comme aux
universitaires comme aux écoliers comme
à toutes les générations
donc je crois qu'il ya un changement de
paradigme nous sommes tous en train
d'apprendre et donc chaque fois qu'on
apprend et on conquiert de la puissance
d'agir alors il y en a qui sont
particulièrement pour lesquels c'est
évidemment important ils ont ils ont une
impact exceptionnel sur la société c'est
notamment les élites public
il se trouve que l'état s'est dotée de
l'institut des hautes études
scientifiques et techniques
c'est peut-être un endroit à mobiliser
plus avancée des travaux souvent
remarquables des promotions qui
gagnerait sans doute à être plus large
donc
donc voilà des choses et puis enfin ce
qu'a dit benoît sur les chercheurs oui
il faut de la recherche sur le numérique
et il faut aussi que cette recherche
percole que cette recherche
aïe irriguer la décision publique et
donc il ne faut pas des chercheurs dans
leur tour d'ivoire et de la même manière
que les fonctionnaires d'autorité ont un
devoir de réserve les fonctionnaires de
connaissances doivent avoir un devoir de
participation il faut et je vous en
avais d'ailleurs auditionné vous
recommande vivement de continuer à le
faire évidemment parce que ils les ont
ils ont évidemment à apporter dans ces
débats alors dernier pointe pour
répondre à votre à votre interpellation
qui va créer quelque chose qui moi me
tient à coeur mais je sais qu'il tient à
coeur a beaucoup évidemment au conseil
et pas seulement au conseil
cette inquiétude sur l'infaillibilité
des dispositifs et la nécessaire par
dhombres qu'il faut accorder aux
individus au cas où les choses se
mettraient à aller mal on pourrait dire
que la démocratie c'est la transparence
de la décision publique et l'opacité des
individus quand le totalitarisme c'est
l'opacité de la décision publique et la
transparence des individus puisque nous
il faut qu'il y ait une forme d'
équilibre entre ces deux points puisque
l'opacité des individus et peut-être
mise à mal ou en tout cas renouvelé et
il faut contrer il faut contrer c'est
c'est
ces risques de dérives alors il nous
faut travailler sur la transparence de
la prise de décision publique et si vous
regardez les grands régimes totalitaires
tels qu'ils ont été documentés par
l'histoire il ne se caractérise pas par
la prise de décision en public par la
disponibilité des documents d'appui et
cette prise de décision et d'ailleurs au
fond tant mieux puisque ça leur permet
aussi de prendre des décisions
spécifiques spécialement idiote
notamment dans le domaine militaire qui
conduit alors effondrement ou économique
du coup cette transparence aujourd'hui
ça peut vouloir dire que les appuis les
outils les logiciels qui font de la
décision publique qui fondent peut-être
la distribution de ces abcès paul bon de
ces petits documents comme la carte
d'identité
ils sont probablement le genre de chose
qu'avait en tête votre interlocuteur
danger peut-être que ces outils
aujourd'hui ne sont pas bien placés sous
la garde de fonctionnaires et qu'il faut
qu'il soit rendu à une garde plus large
peut-être que le fait de les passer en
logiciel libre c'est la manière de les
mettre sous la garde de tous d'en faire
des biens publics qui seront difficiles
ensuite à appropriées pour y ajouter un
champ scandaleux d'orientation
religieuse d imagination raciale ou
n'importe quoi donc peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui il nous faut travailler
sur radicalement sur cette transparence
de manière à sortir par le haut de ce
qui sinon aujourd'hui ton font une
guerre défensive
voilà pour cette audition du conseil
national du numérique par les sénateurs
de la mission d'information sur l'accès
aux documents administratifs et aux
données publiques vous avez notamment pu
largement entendre benoît thieulin
président du conseil national du
numérique est également fondateur de
l'agencé digitale la netscouade
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous
de l'actualité parlementaire cet après
midi à 16h30 pour 24 ans est né à la
séance présentée par delphine girard on
parlera de la proposition de loi
modifiant la loi sur le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté
très bonne journée et sur les chaînes
parlementaires
jeudi à 14h45
suivez en direct la séance